E
ELTIONS.I WOULD DO THEEMOCRATS S
CONTRITOR KELLYANNE NWAYALONWITS
GORNOR MIKE HUCKEE A
FONEWSONTRIBUTORARI FLEIHER.
GOVERNOR, D MY RIGHTWRONG?
AM I MISNG ANYTHING?
SHOU SOMETHING BE DED,SUBTCTED
SEA FIRST OF AL WHEN I
CO ON UR SW, I NEVER SAY
YOU'RE WRO.
Y WOI DOHAT?
I WOULNEVER GET INVID BACK
AM NOT STUPID.
>> Sean: ARIND KELLYANNE
TELL MALL THE TIME.
YR RATE AND ONE OTHE
THINGS HE LKEDBOUT THAT ITOTALLN
SIT AROUND ANDAY WE WISH THE
DEMOCRS WEN'T ING LLOT
HARVESTING.
WE CAN DO TH OR  C SAY
THE
PLED T GAME THAT'S BEING
PLAN
ANWE ND TO W BUTE ALSO
NEED TO GONTO AT
GISLURES WERE REPUICANS
VE MAJORITIES ROSSHE
UNTRY AND WE ND TO ME SURE
TH THERE VOTING WSRE
PASS SO TH THEY TRULY DOKE IT EO
VOTE BUT TLY DMAKE IT HARDFOR P.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHI THAT S
BEEN AT THE REFRONT.
THE CT IS,EPUBLICANS ARE
ALLY GOOD AT CAMPAIGNS.
DEMOCRATARREALLY GOOD ECTIS.
ULTIMATE YOUON'TET INTO
OFCE IYOU DON'T WI
ECTIONS.
UR CAMPAIGN S.
ALL OFOUR GROU GAME AND
EVERY THINIS WONDERFULUT
IT'SBOUT WINNI T VOTES.
ONE ING THAT I DO WANT TO SAY,SM
FELL REPUBLICANSILL LIEN
CARELLY.
QUITLAMI SOMOF THE
CAIDAT FOR WHAT HAPPEN.
IT'SASY TOO THAT.
ARE TH PERFECT?
, THEY'RE NOBUYOU OWSOTHING, THT
GET THEINAME ON THBALLOT ANDGOUC
I WAS PROUD TO SUPRT HERHEL
WALKERWENT TO GEORGITO
CAMPAI WITHIM.
I SEE PEOPLE NOW TRYG TO SAYIT .
MAYBE IT WASITCH McCONNELL
WHO DIDN'T PUTNOUGH RESOURCES
AND EARLY ON.
MAYBE IT WAS ALL OUS WHO
DIDN HELP HIM ENOUGH.I THGHT RSE
BESTHOT HE HAD.
FOPEOPLE TO COMPLAIN ABOUTHIM, N
U CAN DO IT BETT, INTO
YEAR THERE'S ANOER ECTION.
GEOFF THE COUCH,UT YOUR ME
ONHE BALLOT, GO T ERE AND
SHOW US HOIT OUG TO BEONE.STEVEE
>>T'S T ASAD AS PEOPLETHINK ITSS
MANY SEATSN THHOUSES WE
THOUGHT RE GNG TO WIN ANWE
SHOULDAVE ANI WISH WE'D
TAKEN CK THE SENATE BUFOR
TWO ELECON CLES IN A REAL
REPUBLICANGAIN SEATS IN TH
USE.
HAVE TAKEN OV THEOUSE OF
REPRESENTIVE
IN 2018,HE FIRST MTERMNDERPRESIS
IN THE SENE.
NOBO IS MEMBERING THAT
REPUICANS GAINEDEATSN
TRP'S DTERM IN THE SENATE.
AMICA IS YLINGT THE
LITIANS AND YELLINAT
WAINGTON'S TO BEODERATAND
CENTRIST.
THIS IS WHY ERYTNG IS 50
IF BOTPOOLS IN BOTH PAIES TO
MEN TO HAVE ERYTNG THEIRAY
THE WAYNLY,HEY AROUT
OF PLACE WHEREMERI IS.
THE'S REASON THINGS E
OSE DOWN THE MDLE.
THE FIL POT I WILL ME HIS
MECHANS ARALWAYS IMPORTA
INAMPAIGNS BUT CANDIDATE
QUALITY IS ESSENTI.
GOOD CDIDATES LL W.
THBIG ISSUE FOR REPUBLICS
WHIS OUR LEADER,HO IA
NDIDATE ATHEOP.
>> Sean: HERSCHEL I THOUGHT
WAA GO CDIDATE.
PEOPLEISAGREE BUHE GOT
TSPE IN THRUNOFF ABOUT
4: 1.
T OUTSPENT IN E GENERAL
ELECT
REPUICANS COME IN TERMS OF, WE
VER WIN THE POLAR VOTE
WECTUAY WON THE PULAR VOTETHIS .
ITELLS ME THATHEALLOT GAMETHAT G
IS A VERY DIFFENT DEL AN
WHAT WE ARUSEDO SEEI.
EVERY DEL AT WE HAVE USED IN
THE ST.
GO TTHE FAIR
KISSABIES, SHAKE HANDSTAKE
LFIES, DO RALLS.
THAT SMS SECONDARY.
KATIE HOS R
THAT MATTE OR TTERMAN R
THAT MATTE
THE GU HID IN THR
BAMENT, THEY DIDO MEDIA
INTERVIEWSIF THEY BATE IT WAS  E
END, IF ATLL
THEYEVER HAD TANSWEROUGH
QUESONS MATE RAISED A TIME
MON AND DUMPENEGATIVE ADS
ON REPLICA.
THEY DIDN'CAMPGN
ADITNALLY.
>> A COUPLE INGS
I INK  C TYPIFY TH B
REMEMBERING A UPLE OFTRIED-AND-,
MESSENGER,ELIVY.
I THINK REPUBLICANS VE T
BEER MESSAGE.
ARE TALNG ABOUT CME A
RING CTSPHYSICAL,
FINANCIA BORR SECURITY.ANERING .
MESSENGER, BUT IT'S A PRTY
OD CDIDATES.
SOME CE UP SHORTSOME WERFIRST-TE
DEVERY IS E POINT.DELIVERY IS NU
HAVEHE AMERICAN FL BEH
U?
ARE YOU WEARG A RED TIE OR A
PINK DRE CUSMER DELIVE IS
A STEMNOT A YLE.
NEED TO DELIVER THOSE MESSES
THROUGTHOSMESSENGERS WHERE
U LIVE.
I CAN'EXPE YOU THE VOTER T
COME TME SIF YOU'REACCUSTOM TO T
OR PHONE OEMAIOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA A OR ROUGH A
FRIEND OR FALY MEMBER, THASTHKE.
WHAT DOCRA WERE ABLE TO DO
IN GEORGIA AND ELSHERE,
CONNECTED TIUE POLITICS.
THEY SAID TO PPLE  YR
CIRC OF LI, YOUR FAMIL
IENDS, COLLEAGS, DISTANT
ACAINTANCES, MAKTWO
CONNECTIONS.
ON DO LIKEOU
TH'S CLAIC.
NUMB TWO IS MOREMPORTANT,ARE YO?
WHATO  HAVIN COMMON?
D TH YOU'RE ABLEO SATO
PEOP, AHA, YOU WT TO VE
FOR HERSCHELALKEOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.AFTER AL RAPHAEL WARNOCS
VOD 98% OF T TIME AGNST
THE INGS THAT YOU ARE
IMPOANT.
U WANT TO GO WH A Y
STANNG UAND PUTTING UPND
SPEAKING U
HERSCHEL WALR OREPUBLICAN X
OUT THERE REONDI TO YOUR
COERNS.
I SATHE LLOWG, LET M
SHARWITH THE AUDIENCE,E HA
TO HAVE A COND-SECOND RSION,
72ND VERSI AND 70 MINUTE
VERSIG
OPLE WILL LIST
W ARE THE PAIES DIFFERENT,
WHY DOES YR VOTE MTER.
WEEED  GET TSE VES
EARLY.TAKING AIG CHAE SOONE NGEF
WO, A LOT OF TFFICNOT
FEELING SI THAT Y.
IT'S PRO-INCBENTIT'S
ELECTION SEASO
THESARE THE RULES.YOU EITHDAPT .
AS AARTY, AND WEAN DO THISWE CA.
LET ME SAY SETHING
RESPTFUL.TO THE 4REPUBLICAN SATR
WHE WERE MOST  YOU?
WHY REN'YOU  GEOIA
ESTION LIKE TH ALL SHOULDHAVE BE
EN THERE IN ME FORM,
TOWNALL,N RSON, SAYINGHE
FOLLING.
I SERVEDN THE ITEDTATES
EVENT WITH RHAELARNOCK.
'S A TERRIBLE SENAR.
HE DOESN'T REPRENT GRGIA.
HE'S NOT FITO SERVE.
VOT FOR THENFLATION
DUCTN ACT.HE SAID NOING WHEN THD
OUT OF AFGHANIAN.
HE SAINOTHG THAT JOE BIDHAS BEEY
IN THE BORDER ZE DAYS.
THAT WHANEEDS TO HAPPE
ERE WERE THE OER SATORS TO
SAY I WANT HERSCHEWALK, NOT
RAPHAEL WARNOCIN T SENATE
TH ME.
AS TO  ONE LAST QUTION,
ICK ANSWER FM ALOF YOU.ARI.
WHAT IS E ONE BIG
RECOMMENDAON YOU WOULD GE
THE REBLIC PARTY IGENEL.>> YOU E
ON, THBASE ALONE.
EVGOT TO WIN WITTHE BASS
BOAT THAHAAPPEAL TOCENTRISTS AN.
IT'S A BIG PARTY, VE BIGENT.
STILVALID DAY.
>> HEALTHFUL WHAT U ARE R,
NOT WHAT YOU'RAGAIT.
'S EY TO SAYE ARE AGAIT
L
THE OPLEHAT YOU'RE FORWHAT
ARE YOU GOG TOO THAT MAKES
THEIR VES TTER WHEN THEY S
DO ON THE KITCHEN TABLE.
>> SeaOU ARE RIGHT, DON'
UNDEREIMATE THE POWEREPUBLANS TN
THHOUSE ANHAVI THE
MARITY.
LAST WORD, KELLYANNE, AT'S
BIPIECOF ADVICE?>> IILL ADOPT AM
COEAGUE SAID MO AND GR THE
VOTEWHEN YOU CAN.REALLY LOW POIE
MOCRATS AND THBIDE
ADNISTRATION WHI EAR
VONG W HAPPENING THI
REMOVAL CONCER LOSG
NDIDES, WAIT FOR
ELECTI DAYLET'S SURPRISE
ERYO.THE LY PPLE SURPRISEON
ELECTI THEY WERE R